-You said that you're having
an amazing week.
-It's been the craziest week.
Yeah, so, I just got back
from L.A.
and I got to tour
"The Brady Bunch" house.
It's been renovated.
-No, I'm freaking out.
I know everything about it.
I'm watching the show right now.
"The Brady Bunch" -- They
got all the --
They got all the Brady Bunch
together with, like,
the HGTV superstars
and made the house.
-There's all this,
like, old stuff.
I got to use a rotary phone.
By the way,
those things are cool.
Have you used one of those?
You know, the rotary phone.
It was like --
You have to press the button
and then turn the dial.
-You don't press
any buttons at all.
You put four finger in a hole
and then you --
-I got tired just --
-Press the buttons. Oh, my gosh.
You're such a kid.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Australian accent ] They had
crazy things.
They had stairs
you would walk up.
-It was crazy.
-But you did walk up the
classic stairs.
-The classic stairs.
-You and your family
did the pose.
-It was legendary.
-Look at this.
This is the Irwins at
"The Brady Bunch" house.
-All I could think was the theme
song just rolling in my head.
-Dude, that's legendary!
-How awesome is that?
It was so cool.
-I want to check it out.
I love it.
I know -- We were talking
backstage about live stuff.
And you've been on our show
a bunch of times.
But you said they kind of
squeaked out of you.
that you're a super-fan of
"Saturday Night Live."
-Oh, I love "SNL," so it's so
cool, I mean, to be on the show
with Colin and with Michael
and you, of course.
Like, I've always -- Like,
growing up --
-You could have started with me.
-Yeah, sorry about that.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Your cowbell sketch
and all those.
I love it. I love it.
I really do.
I really, really do.
-I want to talk about --
'Cause I love your family.
I see them all the time.
They're here.
Bindi got engaged.
-She did.
-This is amazing to me.
-Yeah, Bindi just got engaged.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How awesome is that?
-Now, Bindi got engaged
at the zoo.
-She did.
Yeah, so, it was right at the
Australia Zoo gardens.
Chandler, who's now
her fiancé --
-I know Chandler, yeah.
-He's the loveliest guy.
He's so loyal
and so kind to Bindi.
So it was amazing.
Look at this. They took a photo.
-How beautiful is that?
Yeah, I got to
photograph it, too.
It was incredible.
-You take great photos.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
-This thing made me laugh,
because -- You sent me this.
I go, "That is gorgeous."
And you're like, "Actually,
since I took the photo,
I wanted to rehearse where
exactly everyone would stand."
-So, before we did it,
Chandler came up to me,
and, you know, of course
he asked Mom and I,
asked our permission,
but he also said,
"I want to make sure
it's perfect,
where we're doing this --
where I'm doing this proposal."
So, I stood in for Bindi
and mocked up
where he was going to propose.
And Bindi hasn't even seen this
photo, but I've got it with me.
So, this is me. It was awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was the happiest moment
of my life.
-Oh, I love you.
I love you, man.
And, so, you are making plans
after the wedding.
Is it gonna be at the zoo?
-Oh, it's going to be
at the zoo.
I'm walking Bindi
down the aisle,
which is just gonna be awesome.
But I've got some big ideas
for the wedding
that I've broached with Bindi.
Like, first of all,
right off the bat,
Idris Elba deejaying.
-Absolutely.
That's the best idea --
Yeah, absolutely.
Go big or go home.
-And then I thought, you know,
you need something
that people are gonna remember,
so I'm thinking
rappelling out of choppers.
Like, Bindi, Chandler
both come out of choppers,
like SWAT team style.
Like, it's got to be
something good,
you know,
something you remember.
-Yeah. And how is that
going so far?
-It was a flat "no"
on the chopper.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-We'll see.
We'll see if we can
push them through.
-I want to talk about
"Crikey! It's the Irwins."
-"Crikey!" Yeah, that's it.
-Second season is starting in
October -- next week.
Over 40 million people
are watching the show.
-Oh, it has been incredible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, thank you.
-And what you do for
animals and for wildlife
is just amazing --
you and your family.
-Thank you very much.
And, you know, a lot of the show
is kind of what we do
with our rescue work,
rehabilitation.
So, rescuing wild animals,
giving them that
second chance at survival --
that's what we're all about.
And we love what we get to do.
It really is incredible.
-And just reminding everybody,
yeah, what we're
fighting for here.
-Exactly. Yeah.
We've only got one planet.
-Yeah. Exactly. Right?
But you're following
in your dad's footsteps
and you are doing a great job.
-Oh, I love it. I really do.
Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-We actually got a photo
of you this season
and we compared it to
a photo of your dad
with the same croc, I believe.
-Yeah, it's the exact same croc.
-That's got to be --
That's just got to be amazing
when you see something
like that.
If you can zoom in a little bit,
you can see --
-That was actually
the same croc.
That's Murray.
And we're both feeding it.
And I actually hadn't seen
this photo before,
so that was completely
by chance.
And, you know, that's why we do
what we do, you know,
is to continue that legacy.
And, you know, with all the
conservation properties
we have all over the world,
all the conservation projects,
the wildlife hospital,
everything we do at the zoo --
it's to make sure
that everything
dad fought for continues.
-Well, he's looking down.
He's looking down
and he's very, very, buddy.
-Thank you very much.
-Very proud. I love you, buddy.
-Robert Irwin, everybody.
Season 2 of
"Crikey! It's the Irwins"
premieres October 5th at
8:00 p.m. on Animal Planet.